use your basic layout for qualitative
slide like that I hope you doubt you
recognize the table format in the
columns you have the different types of
information that you want to talk about
and this is one key thought that
whenever you have different types of
information you will include them in
different columns this is an error that
many people are doing they're just
having a page just with a list of bullet
points and then maybe the first bullet
point is about a general principle the
second bullet point is about an example
the third bullet point is about a
suggestion that you're making you're
mixing different types of logical
information different logical types of
data you should always then separate
this in different columns